RYAN MCDOWELL: Welcome to
Google Cloud Next OnAir.
In this session,
we'll be discussing
Major League Baseball's
data warehouse modernization
journey.
I'm Ryan McDowell, Cloud
Data Engineer from Google.
And joining me today
is Rob Goretsky,
VP of Data Engineering
at Major League Baseball.
Today, we'll be taking a look
at general migration strategy
for cloud data warehouse
migrations and then deep dive
into how and why Major League
Baseball moved their data
warehouse to BigQuery.
Starting off with the overall
strategy of data warehouse
migrations to the cloud,
we've heard from our customers
that traditional data warehouses
are causing tons of pain,
as they are unable to keep up
with today's analytic demand.
There's tremendous complexity
with scaling on demand.
And this is compounded
by the inability
of their incumbent technology
to keep up with data growth.
Traditional data warehouses
were built for batch paradigms
and not for today's
world, where, by 2025,
about one fourth of data
will be streaming in nature.
Access restrictions
and data silos
on-premise inhibit data
sharing and collaboration.
Existing legacy solutions
have the inability
to take advantage of emerging
technologies such as AI
and real time.
And you need to move data
out of your data warehouse
into complex, fragile,
or niche systems that
require PhDs to operate.
Finally, legacy
data warehouses are
extremely expensive to
purchase and maintain.
So how does BigQuery
address these challenges?
BigQuery allows you to
store vast amounts of data.
With BigQuery,
Telegraph Media Group
reduced their query time
from hours to minutes
with up to 4 terabytes
of data processed
in less than one minute.
Blue Apron streams 140 million
events per day with BigQuery.
This has helped them
accelerate business decisions
by one day to near real
time to better manage
food inventory and delivery.
Home Depot is able to
empower business units
to create their own
BigQuery projects
and reduce dependency on IT
budgeting for additional data
warehouse capacity.
20th Century Fox uses BigQuery
to run analytics to pull data
from DoubleClick and
YouTube, and uses TensorFlow
to do audience analysis
on film scripts
and track content patterns
that may better predict
what resonates with audiences.
HSBC needed to cost effectively
upgrade their ageing Teradata
environment and across multiple
regulatory jurisdictions.
By moving to BigQuery, they
were able to save millions over
seven years.
So how should you be thinking
about your data warehouse
modernization strategy?
This diagram shows a high
level legacy architecture
from before the migration.
It illustrates the catalog of
available data sources, legacy
data pipelines, legacy
operational pipelines,
and feedback loops.
Additionally, legacy BI
reports in the dashboards that
are accessed by your end users.
In order to migrate a legacy
data warehouse architecture
to BigQuery, we first need
to go about decomposing
the migration, such
that we aren't left
with a risky big bang cutover.
At Google Cloud, we generally
think about data warehouse
migrations through the lens
of the following framework.
First, through
cloud foundations,
where we set the foundational
cloud infrastructure including
network, IM, and security.
Then risk assessment
and mitigation,
where we evaluate
the operational risk
of the migration and then
develop detailed mitigation
plans.
Third, the migration,
where we actually
execute the migration
comprising of various steps.
Then change management
and learning,
setting up a center
of excellence
within your organization
such that when
the new environment
is cut over, users
are confident from day one.
During the migration,
we generally approach it
from an iterative standpoint.
First, we'll assess
and plan the migration
based on the source environment
and design the destination.
Then we'll work through
an iterative process going
workload by workload or
subject area by subject area,
where we work on migrating
those workloads from the source
system to the
destination system.
This generally comprises of
enterprise setup and security
mapping, migrating schema
and data using BigQuery DTS,
translating queries using
some of our partner tools,
migrating business apps,
migrating upstream pipelines,
verification and
validation to ensure
that once the
environment is cut over,
that users are getting
the same results on top
of that same data sets that
they had on their source system,
performance tuning, and then
of course report and scale
testing.
Now I'll turn it over
to Rob to take us
through how Major League
Baseball completed
their migration journey.
ROBERT GORETSKY:
Thank you, Ryan.
My name's Rob Goretsky, and
I'm the VP of Data Engineering
at Major League Baseball.
Today, I'm going to talk
about Major League Baseball's
migration from Teradata
to BigQuery, including
the motivations for migration,
the actual migration
process itself, and the
capabilities we unlocked when
we completed this migration.
So as a bit of a background,
I oversee the fan data
engineering and business
intelligence teams
at Major League baseball.
We work with fan
transaction and interaction
data generated by internally
developed applications,
including mlb.com and the 30
Major League Baseball club
websites, and our MLB
and ballpark apps,
and third party sites such
as Ticketmaster, tickets.com,
StubHub, and Fanatics.
My team doesn't work
directly with player stats
or on field data,
such as Statcast.
That's the domain
of our baseball data
team at Major League Baseball.
But we do work with the more
traditional user engagement
data to ensure that
we understand our fans
and can bring them closer
to the game of baseball.
This includes personalizing
and targeting marketing and fan
experiences on our
website and on our apps
and sharing our centralized
data with all 30 Major League
Baseball clubs in our
project known as Wheelhouse.
We have over 350
data pipelines that
have been developed over
the last 10 plus years.
Most of our data
sets are not what I
consider to be really big data.
For example, a data set
containing every ticket sale
only contains about
80 million rows
per year for a couple
hundred gigabytes of data.
That said, we do have a
few very large data sets
generated by user interactions
on our website and apps.
These are highly
trafficked, and we
collect every user
interaction and store it
in our data warehouse platform.
In addition, many of the
medium-sized data sets,
such as ticket sales, turn
out to be pretty complicated
in terms of the
modeling and validation
due to the various ways fans
can purchase, exchange, resell,
transfer, and ultimately
share and use these items.
Before our migration
to BigQuery,
we used Teradata as our
data warehouse platform.
We ran data pipelines using
Informatica and Airflow.
MLB employees could
access Teradata directly
by connecting using SQL and
using our BI platform, Looker.
But we didn't have a means
to open up access directly
to Teradata for all 30
Major League Baseball clubs
without major performance
and security implications.
So we set up Airflow pipelines
to essentially copy data
from Teradata to S3 in 30
separate files, one per club
per data set, to
allow clubs to access
that data via S3 and Athena.
This setup presented
several challenges.
The major challenge with
sharing data with clubs
was that we were copying data.
So when we're copying data,
you need to properly identify
which date has changed
each day if you
want to do an incremental copy.
And this was
challenging in cases
where we had late arriving
data or corrections to make
to the data that happened
often after the fact, which
was especially common with
our ticketing data sets.
In addition, if we wanted
to evolve the schema that we
shared with clubs, either by
adding fields or changing data
types, that often
would then require
us to recopy all
historical data out
to the club, which
can be time consuming
and error prone itself.
In addition, if we had
a correction to make,
we often would need to
circulate that on a change log
so that clubs would
be aware that we've
made a change to
the data, that they
should re-fetch
perhaps older data
files that we have published.
This process was also very
much a one-way street.
Clubs didn't have
a way to share data
back with us in a way
that we could easily query
and that would automatically set
up schemas for us to work with.
As our data sources started to
become more and more real time,
another issue with
this setup was
that the system to share
data was itself batch-based.
So even if we were
ingesting data in real time,
to share the data
back with clubs
involved making a copy
perhaps every hour,
or even more frequently,
every five minutes.
But we never really
hit a real time cadence
where clubs could see
the data as it happened.
Other major challenges
outside of the data
sharing with working
with Teradata
included the operational
support overhead.
We maintained a
full time DBA team,
who helped us with
the traditional DBA
tasks such as resolving
performance issues,
monitoring for database dead
locks and long running queries,
resolving backup issues.
And we spent a lot
of time and effort
trying to continue to refine
that part of the system
when really that wasn't
our core concern.
Our core concern was ultimately
providing business data
and analytics to
our organization.
With respect to
performance, we often
found that in spite
of our best efforts
to implement proper workload
management and tuning,
we often would have one bad
apple spoiling the bunch.
A single well-intentioned
user query
that ate up the
entire spool space
or otherwise brought
the system to its knees
was fairly common
and something that we
had to deal with all the time.
Another issue as
we started looking
at scaling our
system on Teradata
was that the compute and
storage were tightly coupled.
This meant that if
we wanted to consider
bringing in some of the
very, very large data sets,
such as our clickstream,
we couldn't do so
without also linearly
increasing our compute, which
came at much additional
cost that perhaps didn't
make sense for us overall.
Furthermore, we found that
integration with third party
tools and apps was limited.
When we were looking to
integrate with new BI
platforms, or data science
tools or analytics tools,
often their support for
Teradata was mediocre at best.
So we ran a project to fully
migrate Teradata from BigQuery
from May through November 2019.
So we ran this entire project
in about seven months time.
At a high level,
the work involved
setting up data replications
from Teradata to BigQuery
and then iterating through
the conversion of ETL jobs
and reports.
We needed to continue to
support live reporting
and agreed that a big bang
cutover happening all at once
was not going to be feasible
or desirable for us.
We instead wanted to
take things in chunks
and ensure that
along the way, we
were validating that BigQuery
was performing as expected
and that data was loading
properly and matching up
with our expectations.
So in order to determine
the order in which
to attack converting and
migrating all of our ETL jobs,
we built a dependency
map that took
a look at which tables
and ETL jobs were upstream
and downstream from each other.
Jobs that were less entangled,
because they were on the leaf
nodes in this diagram, had
fewer downstream dependencies,
and therefore could
be migrated first.
So we worked outside in, if
you will, on this diagram,
where we took those
things that had
the fewest downstream
dependencies, migrated
them first, and then continued
to work our way inwards.
We set up hundreds
of replication jobs
using Apache Airflow very
early on in our project
and throughout the project as
needed as new tables arose.
One of the more time
consuming tasks about this
was determining
exactly which upstream
process we should wait for
before replicating data
to BigQuery.
But we considered this
critical for our success
because we want the
BigQuery to be as close
as possible to being a perfect
match of what was in Teradata.
So for example, if we get a
daily load of StubHub data
and that arrived into
Teradata at 9:00 AM,
we were hoping that we could
have it in BigQuery by 9:01 AM.
So this is not a
hot, hot replication.
It's not necessarily what you
might consider a real time
replication.
But it was basically
close enough
that all of our analysts, data
scientists, report builders, BI
team could immediately
start using BigQuery
very early on in the project
for all of their new work.
This ensured, basically, that
all the data was essentially
in BigQuery as fresh
as it was in Teradata.
So as a result of this carefully
timed setup for replication,
these data
stakeholder teams were
able to start developing
new queries and processes
on BigQuery very early on.
This was great
because otherwise,
if teams were continuing to
build new work on Teradata
during the seven
month migration,
we might have another seven
months worth of migration
to do afterwards, and we might
never finish the project.
So it was important
for us that we
could draw a line
in the sand and say
to all of these
stakeholder teams,
only build new
things on BigQuery.
We're going to replicate
all the data you
need to work on your process.
So for example, for
the data science team,
we're going to make sure
that all the ticket sales
data that you need to
do predictive analytics
is there in BigQuery.
So it's going to look and feel
just like it does on Teradata,
but be available to
you at the same time
so that everything new you build
today, you can start building
on BigQuery.
In the back end, we
continued migrating the ETL
jobs themselves, but by
simply having replication
it unlocked the
ability for most teams
to think about BigQuery as
a live production system
right away.
As we converted ETL jobs,
having replication in place
also allowed us to ensure that
we could do table validation
and match results between
the result of output
from Teradata and BigQuery.
So in order to proceed
with ETL conversion,
we focused on
developing a recipe that
can be followed
by data engineers
without them having
advance knowledge of any
of the business or domain
logic that were contained
within that pipeline.
So we started off looking at
steps that could be automated.
And we spent some time
upfront developing tooling
to automate those processes.
For example, we wrote
shell or Python scripts
that would simply pull pieces
of SQL out of parts of our code
so that we could
quickly identify which
pieces needed to be translated.
We also looked for
cases where there
were Teradata specific
function calls or Teradata
specific commands being issued.
And we were able to pull
those out and translate
those en mass.
So this meant that for the first
month or so of our project,
we weren't necessarily doing
an end-to-end ETL conversion
just yet.
But we were building
out the tools
that would enable us to then
move very quickly through all
of the others.
So once we got through building
out a lot of the automation,
the remaining steps was a
majority of the project,
and it was done by
our data engineers.
This involved places
where either it
was too difficult to build
automation for something,
or because we wanted to have
validation done by a human who
could look over something
and ensure that it
passed proper sanity checks.
Also working with
Informatica, we
found that there was no easy
way to automate mass changes.
So a lot of those involved
clicking through the interface
and just manually making
changes in the GUI.
So with respect to
automated components,
one tool that
helped us immensely
was a SQL transpiler tool by a
company called CompilerWorks.
This tool accepts
Teradata SQL as input
and then outputs BigQuery SQL.
So while minor SQL differences,
such as function name changes
or small syntax changes,
could have been resolved
by a simple regex
search and replace,
more complex cases
involve having
a deeper understanding
of the SQL structure
and the data types
that underlie them.
Here's a really common case that
we had that used the Teradata
specific Qualify clause.
The CompilerWorks
tool was able to pull
the clause used within
Qualify and rewrite
the query as an inner query.
Doing this at hand would have
been error prone at best.
Another major advantage we found
when using the CompilerWorks
tool is that it became aware
of the actual schema itself,
including the data types.
So BigQuery is pretty
specific about data types.
For example, if a field
as a data type of integer,
it may not allow you
to directly insert
a numeric value without
casting it to an integer.
Teradata was a bit
more lax about this.
So this is the kind of thing
that a translation normally
would trip up on
time and time again.
The CompilerWorks's tool,
being aware of the data
type of a column, when it
parsed and read the SQL it
was actually able to
automatically apply
the proper cast or conversion
statement to it for us
so that the syntax
would be valid
and would run immediately.
When we were done
converting an ETL pipeline,
we continue running the
original pipeline in Teradata.
But we'd run the converted
pipeline side-by-side
in a prod parallel environment.
In this diagram here, we
see the Airflow DAG diagram
of our original ETL
with Teradata operators
embedded within.
And on the right hand side,
we see the exact same pipeline
with BigQuery operators
embedded within.
And we set these up to run
in two separate environments,
but generally at the same time
of day with the same input data
so that we could basically
do a side-by-side check
that the output
data would match.
To further assist us with
this table validation,
we looked in the marketplace
for tools that would essentially
allow us to run a diff
between two tables,
similar to how you
run a diff when
you're using Git to look at code
review or pull request reviews.
We couldn't find anything
that fit our needs exactly
in terms of allowing us to do
a table-to-table comparison
by joining on the primary
key and then telling us
if rows were missing
from one table or another
or if rows had
fields that differed
in one table or another.
So we built our own tool.
Our own tool,
essentially, ran queries
and generated SQL
for us on BigQuery
to take the output of the
replicated Teradata ETL
and compare that with the
output of the BigQuery ETL.
This would quickly
surface to us if there
were either differences
in the row count,
or in rows missing on
one side or the other,
or if there were
field differences.
At this point, this was
one of the few pieces
of the project that really
required domain and analyst
expertise, because if the
diff tool showed differences--
and it often would
show some differences--
we needed to make
a business decision
about whether those
differences in the output
were relevant for our use case.
For example, if there
was a field that
simply had to create
a date or a timestamp,
we would expect those
would be slightly different
between Teradata
and BigQuery, simply
because of the slightly
different runtime when
those jobs completed.
However, if there was a field
such as a financial charge
value, we would expect
that generally those
should match up exactly.
So if there was a difference in
those and it was significant,
you would need to dig in further
to see where in the pipeline
something was
either mistranslated
or something perhaps was thrown
off for some other reason.
So having a tool
like this allowed
us to have the data engineers
spit out conformed output
that then we could pass
to analysts and end users,
and more experienced users of
the business analytics side
to help us understand
what the differences were.
So taking a look again
at where we went,
we took a look before
at our data architecture
before our BigQuery migration,
including this middle layer
where we had landing data as
a copy for club data access
in our Wheelhouse project.
After BigQuery
migration, you see
that we've removed that
middle layer completely.
Consumers of data, whether
they are at clubs outside
of our network, or internal
users, or data science,
or other constituent
teams, are all
looking at the exact
same copy of the data.
There is not a second
copy made of any data.
This means that if we
load data in real time,
it's available to those
consumers in real time.
And it also means
that we don't have
to deal with all the
discrepancies that
arise by making copies of data.
So we mentioned a few
of the benefits here.
And we're going to
summarize them here.
With respect to
democratization of data,
I will do a live demo
here in a few moments
to show how we could use
the BigQuery tools to very
easily share data
and securely ensure
that we only share
a subset of data
with the proper stakeholders.
With respect to
performance and scale,
we saw that some of
our large queries
had a 50% reduction in
runtime without really
any additional work
done on our end.
And similarly, we saw
that certain data sets,
such as our
clickstream data, which
consists of over 300 terabytes
a year in uncompressed data,
were able to be loaded into
BigQuery, whereas previously we
couldn't even consider
doing something like that.
So we instead needed to
keep really large data
sets like those in separate
silos within a Hadoop ecosystem
to process them.
Having them all in one place was
one of the single biggest user
requests that we had
gotten, because users often
want to join the clickstream
data with other data sets,
such as our ticketing
or shop data.
For security, instead of
having to have separate user
rights and roles and
credentials, all of this
is centrally managed
by our InfoSec team
by way of our integration
with Okta and G Suite.
So users are set up
with groups within Okta.
And those flow
automatically into G Suite,
which then flows automatically
into BigQuery Roles
and Responsibilities.
This means we don't have
to have any time spent
on setting passwords,
worrying about who
has compromised access,
who might otherwise
leave the organization.
All of it is set up
centrally in one place.
Developer happiness is
really a key one for me
and my team, in
that we just found
that everybody who
worked with the system
understood things
right away with it
and generally had less
gotchas than what they did
with Teradata.
More specifically, we found that
one of the biggest advantages
is that we can often
Google if we're not
sure about exactly how
to do something and find
a helpful Stack Overflow
answer almost right away.
This wasn't necessarily
the case with Teradata,
which was generally the
domain of enterprise companies
and larger customers,
and really wasn't
as widely available
to the masses
as something like BigQuery is.
Where with BigQuery,
there's a free tier
that any engineer can jump in
and try things out with it.
It just means that there is
a wider mindshare for it.
It means that there's more
documentation and more
community support for it.
And we find that helpful
time and time again.
With respect to
features, we're finding
that features are consistently
added that help us
out without breaking
anything for us
and without requiring any
downtime for upgrades.
With Teradata, we were
pinned to a specific version
for several years at a
time because an upgrade
was a major process.
For us with BigQuery,
we just take a look
at our system one morning
and we see release notes
and there's new features.
And it's like
opening a goody bag.
You immediately have some new
toys to play with every day.
So with respect
to flexibility, we
found that early
on in our testing,
we didn't want to make a
big commitment about going
with BigQuery.
But we loved that we could
use the on-demand model
to load some data, even
some of our larger data
sets, and try things
out without having
to make any upfront commitment.
The operational overhead has
been significantly reduced.
Right now backups are automatic.
And one of the things
that our team really loves
is the ability to
simply ask BigQuery
to present a copy of a table
anytime in the last seven days.
So if you're trying to validate
a data load issue that happened
last night, you can
simply ask BigQuery
to present the copy of
the table from yesterday.
And you could take a
look at what changed.
Similarly, if you've
ever accidentally dropped
a production table, and I know
none of us have ever done that,
you can easily undelete a
table for up to three days
with a single SQL command.
So there's no need to run to the
DBA and ask for a tape backup
and have your heart
skip a beat as you
think about the implications
of what's happened there.
BigQuery handles all of that for
us in a really easy to use way.
And finally, with
respect to cost,
again, the on-demand pricing
allowed us to start things up
at a low run rate.
And then once we found
what we stabilized at,
we could basically
purchase reserve slots
and make sure that our cost
was fixed going forward,
that we wouldn't
have sudden spikes.
So now I'm going to
jump into a live demo
where I'm going to show how
we democratized data at MLB.
And in this case, I'm going
to walk through an example
where we are going to take a
data set that contains data
for all 30 Major
League Baseball clubs
and show how we would share it
with just one of those clubs
while applying security to
ensure that that club can only
see their own data.
I'm going to jump in from the
perspective of a single club,
in this case the
Yankees, and show
how that club is able
to access that data,
and even run queries
with their own data
combining and joining
with that data.
To demonstrate how BigQuery's
data set sharing and authorized
views allowed us to democratize
data access at Major League
Baseball, I'm going to walk
through a small example here.
I'm in the BigQuery console,
logged in as a Major League
Baseball employee.
So I have access to data
across all 30 teams.
For example, here I've set
up a small dummy schema
of tickets fact table that
contains one row per ticket
sale transaction.
As Major League
Baseball, we have access
to all 30 teams' data.
And one of our goals
here is to ensure
that we share that data
with each of the 30 clubs
so that they can make their
own local business decisions.
So the goal would be to
share the Giants data
with just the Giants
and the White Sox data
with just the White Sox.
In our first iteration of
Wheelhouse data sharing,
we accomplish this by setting up
30 copies of the data each day.
So we would run queries
to segment out the data
and pull all of the Giants
data and put that in one file.
Then we'd pull data
for the White Sox,
and put that in another file.
This involved making
copies of the data, which
incurs issues when perhaps you
have data that has been updated
later on after the file
was produced perhaps,
other data synchronization
issues, and just
other challenges in making sure
that you stay in sync with what
you have copied out.
So with BigQuery, this
gets a lot easier.
So to demonstrate
this, first of all,
logged in as Major
League Baseball,
I can do a demo query to
show that I can run something
like a sum of the quantity from
this table across all 30 teams.
So as Major League
Baseball, I can
see that some of the quantity
broken down by the team name,
for example.
And we can see that
I do have access
here as Major League Baseball
to all 30 of the clubs' data.
So now if I want to just
share data with the Yankees,
for example, we
should be giving them
access to just the slice of
the data pertinent to them.
The way we accomplish
that is by creating a data
set that we share data
with the Yankees in.
Assuming one doesn't
already exist,
I can go into BigQuery's
console and simply set up
a data set that we will use
for sharing with the Yankees.
And within that data set,
I'm going to create a view.
And this is a standard
SQL view that's
just going to say,
we're going to create
a view of the next_demo_Yankees
tickets as select star
from the parent data set, where
the team name is the Yankees.
So we're just going
to say where the team
name is equal to Yankees.
So this is a standard SQL view.
And we'll see that
it gets created.
And we can check it out that the
DBL is available here for us.
And it's our pretty
traditional SQL view,
where it just gives access
to that slice of the data.
Most data warehouse systems
and database systems do not
allow you to share
access to the view
without sharing access
to the underlying table.
And this is where BigQuery's
authorized view differs.
So normally, I couldn't
share this view
without actually giving access
to the entire base table, which
we wouldn't want
to do, because we
want to give the
Yankees only access
to their subset of the data.
So all we have to do here to
enable this functionality is
on our parent data set,
set up the authorized view
to say that this new view that
we've created in the child data
set is authorized to
access the parent data set.
So in this case
here, we're going
to say that the
next_demo_Yankees view is
authorized to access
the next_demo_sales,
the parent data set.
With that in place,
all I now need to do
is figure out who I want
to share the data with.
And this works very similarly
to Google Drive or Google Docs
sharing, where you simply
provide a list of G Suite email
addresses or G Suite groups.
For this demo, I'm going to be
using just a single dummy email
address I set up.
But in production, we
actually use G Suite groups
to enable entire groups of
users at a time that are
managed locally by the clubs.
So all I have to
do to share data
is give it a list
of email addresses
that I want to share with.
So I'll use my dummy
email address here
of yankeestaff@gmail.com.
And I tell it that I
want to give access
just to view the data,
not to modify it,
not to modify the DBL.
It's a read-only access
that I'm providing here.
And much like any other Google
Suite sharing, that's it.
We're done.
So now we can see that we
immediately have given access
to a set of users or a user.
So I'm going to
switch gears here now.
I'm going to switch over
to my browser window
to see what the
Yankees would see.
I'm logged in here
on this browser
window as the Yankees staff.
And initially, I
would have had access
to perhaps nothing, if nothing
had been shared with me
yet from Major League
Baseball, essentially.
But if I refresh
my screen now, I
have access right
away to that data set
that's been given to me here.
So I have this
tickets data set here.
And I can start running
queries on it right away.
For example, the same sum
of the quantity that I
was running on the
parents data set,
I can run here all the same.
And I'll see here that
as the Yankees user,
I'm only getting access to
that slice of data that's
pertinent to the Yankees.
So in this case here, it's
just that 10,000 rows.
What makes this
even more powerful
is that I can bring
my own data that I
may have locally and not shared
with Major League Baseball.
And I can join that
across these data
sets so there's no
barriers here of data silos
where datas in different
data sets can't be joined.
If you have access to data, no
matter what the data set is,
you can join across it.
So for my example
here, let's imagine
the Yankees have a
small local sheet
of promotions they are running.
And they want to analyze
which of those promotions
generated the most sales.
So if this is a sheet
they may have in a CSV,
they could go ahead
and use BigQuery's UI
to very easily upload
that data from the CSV.
We point to that CSV.
We give it a table name here.
We'll call it promos.
And we'll tell it to
automatically detect
the schema.
And just like that, within
a few moments there,
we will have a table
created for us locally.
This would be a table
that the Yankees
have access to that otherwise
is not shared anywhere else.
Now a join could be written
that combines those two
things together.
So I've written
this query up here
that says, let's take the
data that Major League
Baseball would
have shared with us
and the tickets
data set, and we're
going to do a join with the
promos data on the game date.
And this will allow us
to run that query that
crosses those two
data sets and sees
which promotion has the
highest overall quantity sold.
So in this example here, we see
that the highest quantity sold
was a t-shirt.
That led to the
most quantity sold,
other than no promotions,
which were there
because perhaps we didn't
fill in all the promo data.
So you can see how
this paradigm of being
able to join across
data sets you're
authorized to allows you
to have different access
patterns for data, while still
allowing centralized querying
across them.
RYAN MCDOWELL: Thanks, Rob.
And thank you for joining
us for Google Cloud Next.
Be sure to check out some of
our other great data analytics
sessions.
Thank you.